Hikaru congratulations two and a half
out of three a very good bounce back day
after yesterday's let's say to
tumultuous uh they did you feel that way
as well yeah I mean I did what I did
last time I was here two weeks ago
pretty much started off playing uh
terrible chess and then I found a way to
recover on the blitz after a very poor
rabbit portion I mean this this event
obviously is a lot shorter it's only
three days
um but yesterday was was terrible I mean
I lost two games I shouldn't have lost
uh I I felt like I was overpressing a
little bit too much in both those well
maybe not the on game but I mean at
least in the first game for sure I just
completely overpressed it um and I lost
him a chakra and but then today I mean I
I kind of played something I think was
dubious against Lenny in this first game
this this whole e495 thing I think he
probably could have played something
better and I mean the fact that I was in
trouble but I mean it's very hard
because like I don't know whether I mean
I feel like they're generally are two
approaches either you try to be like
very solid in place symmetrical or you
try to be very creative and do something
different
um and I I feel like I've been I
basically say you know what I don't want
to play a normal game it's going to be
chaotic and hopefully I'm not just
losing in the complications
um but like in this first game I think I
was just losing I thought this D5 was
very strong
yeah and then for some reason he didn't
go 19 yeah 92 and F4 of course yeah why
it's just much better
yeah yeah he didn't do this I mean I saw
this during the game and I thought um
this basically forces you keeping the
Knight on it I played E3 ef2 well okay
there's no 93. yeah yeah but I mean ef3
ef3 F4 is what I was going to play but
it still it looks it looks horrible I I
don't know it's only 0.5 or 0.9.9 only
with the only move space no I mean I was
gonna do this but it just it looks
ridiculous I mean it just looks so
stupid
um but hmm okay it's only wow it's not
actually just losing the way I thought
so like I thought it was probably very
bad but I played it anyway and then uh
Lenny a I mean I guess this is where I
say it's it's good that um it's good
that I don't play chess professionally
anymore because I feel like Lenny if I
had to say one thing about him I feel
like in the in the last couple years in
particular he's trying to be too solid
like you've seen it here in many events
like you saw it in the sink filled cup
there were a couple positions he had
great positions and he tried to simplify
uh in the blitz against me he tried to
simplify when he was completely winning
for no reason and in this game also he
tried to simplify like even here like
Knight D5 well first of all go back one
move so I gambled here because after
Queen C1 I take it takes I wasn't sure
whether I should take or not because
basically his Knight B5 here and I think
I'm again yeah yeah this is winning of
course yeah yeah so like I I mean I I so
I kind of like I was using the meta
against them based on what I've seen in
recent times because I I just assumed
okay if he finds 95.5 but if he doesn't
play an ip5 and he plays the automatic
capture which I kind of thought he might
do based on what he's done recently then
I'm back in the game and then later he
played this bishop D4 move which was
just I mean horrible so that was the
strategy from the beginning take some
risks and basically base your decisions
on the fact that he's a bit reluctant to
take extra risks yeah you you've just
seen in a lot of events recently where
he's looking for the simplification even
when he's pressing or potentially
outright winning and so I just thought
I'll do it I mean the tournament's going
terribly so did you feel like you're in
a must win situation in the first couple
of games I mean I wasn't looking at most
when you you just don't want to lose
every game because I mean the thing
that's annoying is so last year when I
played the 960. it was very similar
first game I played shocker also and um
and I think we reached some endgame
where I could have forced to draw on uh
Bishops of Ops color end game instead I
blundered and lost that then I think I
lost in like 10 moves or something the
Shanklin in the second game and I think
I lost Lenny in the third game of the
day so like after that experience last
year I mean I just kind of didn't want
to do the same thing uh and so I was
just just kind of playing I wasn't I'm
not thinking about first place that's
like that happens it happens so that
wasn't my thought at least at the start
of the day but but then I mean the
second game I thought was was very very
good I got a nice big Advantage from the
very start
and that was against Hillary and Peter
oh yes yeah I mean but this was also
very funny so so like it's very funny
because Peter and Gary analyzing and
like when you make a move and your
opponent doesn't move right away
sometimes you just get up go look at the
screen to see what other players have
done and it was funny because I saw the
chakra I had also played Knight G3
against Gary on another board and um and
both of them were thinking for like five
minutes I think I'll move one which is
pretty pretty funny and then of course
Gary also just got blown away out of the
opening too in this game against shock
and and my game of course I think was
just it was felt very pleasant although
I thought there might have been a
computer line if you go to this position
how are you analyzing these positions
for those 10 minutes before I'm not I'm
not were you looking at it were you
analyzing no no I mean I just don't I
don't I don't want to waste my energy
analyzing I figure I'm just gonna look
at it for five minutes and intuitively
try to pick what I think is the best
um and I think I've done a pretty good
job actually for the most part I mean
this last game was the only one where I
was really kind of confused um that was
the game yeah this game against
um against slovan it's the only one
where I really was very very unsure like
I didn't have any real idea what I was
supposed to play for from the from the
very start just it seemed kind of weird
um
what were the pieces that you were
focusing on improving early on well I
mean there's this thing that I spoke
about I spoke about on my recap
yesterday and I've spoken about it
recently so I had this this something
similar to this against Magnus when I
played him in Norway 2018 where he was a
queen on A1 in The Rook on B1 and I
remember when we looked at the engines
at the time they liked playing like some
of these early A4 some of these early B4
so it's like the one thing is when you
have the queen The Rook in the corner
like this sometimes you push now
obviously I don't remember what the
other pieces were but I remember there
was something of a theme so that was one
thing that I thought was maybe you push
push one of those pawns early but uh
yeah B3 or B4 something like that I
don't I don't know I mean probably not
here but uh it's just one of those
things that I thought me either
something like that but in general I
just wasn't sure what I was doing in
this game after F3 yeah I played F6 and
I saw Holly Reza played 97 instead of
Essex was also kind of interesting but
um
yeah and then I was I actually I mean I
was very sad that he took on D5 because
I was really hoping that Lavon would
play D5 Bishop B5 this is what I was
hoping to do but then after D4 wow this
is wow this is actually just winning I
mean I thought I thought the sack The
Exchange Act was very interesting but
wow minus 1.4
are you surprised about the assessments
I mean I I thought I looked interesting
I thought I I didn't think it's probably
worse because I I mean I have this big
pond Center but again like I'm kind of
shocked this is just yeah it's just
losing wow
no it's just bizarre The Exchange stocks
that is the one thing like exchange tax
seem to be the balance is very different
it seems like a 960 than a regular chess
um but yeah Lavon didn't do this and I
thought I was just better
um throughout the game but I think You
Were Somehow yeah I mean I got the
center and that's all that mattered but
but somehow I couldn't
I mean I thought I thought what I did
was very very principled here with B5
and then yeah he took place this
perhaps came to B7 was that was somehow
working that was the move we wanted oh
another one 95 or K7 yes Rook 87 B4 was
it another one yes
and if rookie six instead
wow okay
but uh allowing the queen on B6 is no I
mean somehow yeah but also I mean
there's yeah Knight A3 and C4 I guess is
winning uh
yeah but I mean this one's also kind of
hard to play because now I can go Knight
B1 and there's I mean at least at least
without like an hour on the clock it's
kind of hard to assess this as being all
like all that great
um yeah I got this end game and then I
mean I don't know if I was supposed to
Sack or not I mean
here okay so it's okay I feel very good
okay I feel validated that I sacked
because I mean the thing is like I
didn't want a sack but I wasn't really
sure how I'm gonna get an end game where
I'm winning I thought like Rook a two
rookie six on Rook D6 thing for example
and I didn't see it and I mean even King
C5 I thought there was a trick to him
King C5
was it Bishop no Bishop E4 I can take no
no I can take the Rooks or the king
morons but there was something I saw
here was it rookie uh Rick d1's also
move okay but
yeah I mean I just I wasn't sure about
this then I thought Rook D3 I could
never lose so it makes sense and if he
plays the wrong way I definitely am
winning so I thought there was Zero risk
um but I thought Lavon played this very
well actually
um yeah rookie eight and yeah it's a
real tragedy that Bishop A3 doesn't work
but schweather is what I wanted to play
this is my initial idea because white
goes Rook CCA for example
oh no apparently I'm just a bad chess
player I thought I could play wait why
does rugby two not win
King C1 ah because I saw it because I
saw King A1 Rook C2 which I think is
just winning yes because then I have
Rook C1 and B2 with the fork and yeah it
seems like okay maybe not maybe I'm just
terrible chess player again
ah cause there's rookie 400 K8 okay yeah
yeah I didn't see it so actually what I
saw during the game was instead of this
I thought that he could play um if you
go yeah like if you go back to King A1
or go back to sorry yes um go back one
more
so no no go back instead of Rook C8
yeah so the line that I saw was rookies
Rook C3 and then I thought Rook B2 King
A1 B4 but then then Rook CC it ends to
draw
um that's why there's no more uh before
Square yeah exactly so this is what I
saw and I thought it was a draws and I
then I played Rook D2 but I think Lavon
just played it very very well I mean I
thought what he did was correct yeah yep
yep I mean sometimes you can only tip
your hat
um
yeah and it didn't seem like the balance
yeah because I mean again there's I got
I got into this Rook Pawn end game but
it was never never quite there so it's a
little bit disappointing not to win this
one um during the position I had but
again it was messy and uh it's still two
and a half a good day still within
Striking Distance to the leaderboard
well I mean I guess I do play alireza so
I guess if I beat him that's a big trust
I mean who cares I mean the thing is you
just try to you try to play good shots
and it's very unpredictable too because
like the opening decides everything if
you get a good position it's very easy
to play I mean it's a lot of fun you're
just enjoying it like the Civil game but
if you get a bad position right away
it's very honest I mean you're just like
why am I playing 960 instead of playing
uh playing normal chess I'd much rather
just Blitz out 20 moves of theory um so
it cuts both ways but uh again at least
today I I thought I played pretty well I
thought I calculated well I think my
time usage was much better than
yesterday and it's it's all very good he
got to go give your rest we'll see you
tomorrow thank you congratulations to
you here